hey friends welcome back to the channel
this is a clip from my interview with
logan yuri the behavioral scientist
turned relationships therapist to turn
best-selling author of the book how to
not die alone and in this clip logan is
sharing her tips on how to become better
at relationships and how to be a better
life partner we might think that we
shouldn't need a video or a book
explaining how to be better at
relationships and how to be better at
love because that's something that
should come naturally and instinctively
to us but clearly you know 50 of
marriages and in divorce loads of people
struggling relationships clearly there
there is a need for education on the
topic this is a fantastic book by the
way and you should definitely check out
my full interview with logan but here is
a clip on how to be better at
relationships let's go how to be a
better life partner so some of it is
just knowing yourself and knowing your
stuff so what keeps you in the safe zone
where you're happy you're confident i
like this word that i invented called
confident it's when you're calm and
confident how do you stay in your
confident mode and what are your
triggers so for some people let's say
they're anxiously attached their trigger
is when their partner's traveling and
isn't in touch they get upset and they
move into the danger zone so
what i would recommend to that person is
know your triggers know what you need
and learn how to ask for it so really
part one is going deep inside yourself
and knowing yourself and doing the work
another thing is learning how to have
card conversations so
sometimes people say to me oh i met this
guy we're getting along so well we never
fight
that's not something that i think you
need to optimize for lots of very happy
couples fight fighting is about being
passionate my mother-in-law who's a
therapist says when couples tell me they
don't fight i also say do you not have
sex because for her and her mind those
things go along it's about having
friction and working through stuff so
learning how to have hard conversations
learning how to say things like
i'm sure you're familiar with
non-violent communication but when you
think of that at the moment
oh really yeah i love nvc i i use it all
the time so for people who aren't
familiar with it it's a framework for
expressing yourself in a way that
helps you
get heard and helps you
kind of speak in a way that really
expresses what's going on for you so the
format is when you
insert a specific thing that happened
i felt and you have to use an emotion
word so it can't be something that's
judging them like
i felt
left behind it would be something like i
felt sad i felt enraged i felt depressed
whatever it was
because of my need for blank so you
explain to them why this matters so
recently i had this in a work
conversation where i said when i wasn't
part of that decision making it made me
feel
sad because of my need for
inclusion and then you say in the future
i request that you blank and you say a
specific request that they can agree to
or talk to you about and so just
learning things like that like how to
communicate how to stand up for yourself
how to have boundaries all of that is
super important
another one is what we talked about
earlier around bids so making bids to
connect with your partner and turning
towards their bids so if you are
working really hard and your partner
clearly wants to talk do you make a
choice to close down your laptop and
talk or do you say not now i'm in the
middle of editing and i'm in a flow
state or maybe you can just say i'd love
to hear that story can we talk in 20
minutes and so these small decisions
that you're making and i think another
one that we haven't talked about that
much is sex uh dan savage has this
concept of ggg this is his secrets to
good sex so it's um good
which means being skillful how can you
develop your sexual skills
giving how can you be generous in bed
and game how can you be willing to
experiment or give your partner what
they want within reason and so i would
also invest in
learning how your body works how
somebody else body works asking for what
they want giving feedback because
while
some very happy relationships don't have
great sex lives for many people that
does matter and how can you take your
own sex life into your own hands hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day